where's kamala harris the vp mostly mia
since afghanistan and never where she's
supposed to be the borders are never
once at the border she was appointed
chair of the space council but never
hosted a meeting and the only job she
created were child actors she hired to
make herself look relatable
so do people even know kamala harris or
what she's been up to i hit the streets
to find out
[Music]
who's this
that's uh vice president kamala harris
or kamala harris your choice you not to
say kamala yuck kamala harris our lovely
vice president who's this
i can't even tell you who is that take a
guess
that's the mayor that's bill de blasio
i'm confused oh cheetah um
the
governor that's harris right that's
harris yes i know what's his uh who's
maya higher oh no she's a vice president
and that little girl was me
[Music]
what do you like about kamala harris
nothing what do you think kamala harris
stands for herself unity equality what
has she done to support
equality i don't know
[Laughter]
she doesn't necessarily
know what the public wants that kind of
plays out into
an administration that doesn't really
know what they're doing
to see here
what good do you think she's done as
vice president
obviously not much because i would have
heard what has she done for the people
they doing a lot they're doing a lot yes
they do a lot i just can't name
everything ah she opened up the borders
we did it joe
what do you think she's doing well
i just feel like this administration has
um
basically destroyed black and spanish
communities what do you think kamala has
done well
covering for biden's house
i'm not sure i really don't know what
she's done i'll be honest with you i'm
giving them a fair chance just let me
know what's going on what are you
waiting for huh what do you think kamala
harris is helping joe biden with i don't
really think she's helping him with
anything i don't even know what joe
biden is actually doing we all do things
every day as part of our jobs
that
get us what we need to do you know i you
know i do dog walking it's kind of what
kamala does with joe
if you were vp what would you advise joe
biden to be doing right now
to pick up where lincoln left fourth
back and give the peoples their 40 acres
of the meal you think kamala should
give people reparations right reparation
that's a new language give me a price
tag per person let's say a million
dollars a year
one million dollars
if you were
kamala harris giving advice to joe biden
what would you tell the president resign
man come on man to do what is best for
the country as a whole
what is going to push our country
forward instead of keeping it for a lack
of better terms a lot in the stock of
the world
[Laughter]
do you remember who i am from from tv
did we work together um waters
and this is my world
that that's quite a catchy catch line
you got there how long you work on that
years
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else